عندما تقرر خساره بعض الوزن مباشره تفكر
في حساب كميات الطعام وممارسه الرياضه
ولمن ياخذ الموضوع بجديه اكبر بالتاكيد
سيحسب السعرات الحراريه في الطعام لكن
فريقا جديده من الخبراء يرى ان حساب
السعرات وسيله غير مجديه وقد تكون ضاره
احيانا خاصه اذا تحولت لهوس يزيد من العبء
النفسي على الفرد اختصاصيات والتغذيه
الرافدين لحساب السعرات الحراريه يؤكدون
ان هذه العمليه لا تعتمد فقط على نوعيه
الطعام بل تتاثر بعدد الكبير من المتغيرات
الفرديه مثل العمر والحركه والى ما لا
نهايه من التعقيدات التي تصل الى عدد
البكتيريا الموجوده في الامعاء فهل فعلا
حساباتنا خاطئه كل هذه السنين ونحن ودقيق
في ملصقات الاغذيه والسعرات الحراريه التي
تحتوي
[موسيقى]
تنضم الينا من عمان
بحسن ما تقول الدراسه حساب السعرات
الحراريه لا يؤدي او ليس مهم لدرجه فقدان
الوزن
صباح الخير نادين وسهام وصباح الخير لكل
مشاهدين صباح العربيه طبعا بدايه خلينا
نعرف شو يعني سعره حراريه لسعراتي الطاقه
اللي بتكون موجوده بالقطع الاطعمه
المتناوله وهذه الطاقه لما تكون تفوق
احتياجات الجسم وقتيها راح يتم تخزينها
الى داخل الدهون والمعادله اللي بتقول انه
اذا احنا قلنا من تناول السعرات الحراريه
في وقتيها الجسم راح يلجا للدهون المخزنه
كمصدر للطاقه تعويضا لا نقص ال- اللي صار
وهي معادله صحيحه 100% ولكن الاعتماد على
فكره فقط الاحتساب سعرات الحراريه الداخلي
والخارجه لوحده غير كافي لعمليه انقاص
الوزن لانه هناك عوامل اخرى بتدخل او
بتاثر بعمليه التمثيل الغذائي وايضا
معدلات الحرق بالجسم ومن اهم هذه العوامل
هي الجينات العوامل الوراثيه العوامل
الجينيه وكمان نوعيه الاطعمه لها دور
الاكبر بالتحكم او بخساره الوزن همم ممكن
انا اتناول امير سعره حراريه من همم قطعه
من البسكويت او اللوحه شوكلت وايضا ممكن
اتناول نفس القدر من السعرات الحراريه من
حبه فاكهه ولكن تاثير همم السعرات على
الجسم بتكون مختلفه لانه لما انا اخذ معظم
السعرات الحراريه من السكريات العاليه راح
تؤدي الى اثار على الصحه منها مقاومه
الانسولين اللي بتادي الى صعوبه بين نزول
الوزن فالموضوع لا يتعلق فقط بحساب
السعرات الحراريه مقدر حماسك ولكن حيرتيني
وحيرتونا انتم والدراسات يعني ما جاء ماذا
يجب علينا ان نفعل اذن
نعم يعني سلاري رياضه ولا رياضه
يعني بتفكر انه خلص انا بدي بدي يعني انزل
من الوزن بس بدي احسب سرعه الحريه اللي
بدنا نحكي انه نحن لازم مش بس نحسب
السعرات لازم ايضا ناخذ بعين الاعتبار
نوعيه الاطعمه لانه نوعيه الاطعمه بتلعب
دور اساسي اما التقليل من الشهيه او تظبيط
الجوع وايضا التحكم بالهرمونات فلازم ناخذ
بعين الاحتمال الاعتبار نوعيه القطر
وما يعني يتحول عندنا الفكره لهوس بعد
السعرات الحراريه الفائده من معرفه
السعرات الحراريه هي تحديد كميه الطعام
وليس وليس الحساب السعرات اللي هي 100 ولا
50 احنا بس بنقدر بشكل عام الكميه اللي
انا باحتاجها حتى ما انا اخذ اكثر من
احتياجاتي وهذا اللي انا باستفيد منه لما
انا اعرف السعرات الحراريه لانه لما يصير
في عندي او لما انا اصير اتبع اساليب اللي
هي اسير احسب 100 ولا اثنين او استخدم
الميزان هي مش مش وسيله عمليه او بعض
الاتباعها كمان حياه لذلك انا لازم بدل ما
انا افكر هذا الطبق قديه فيه سعرات حراريه
لا انا اركز انه يكون هذا الطبق همم
متوازن فيه جوده الاطعمه فيها من الاطعمه
ذات قيمه غذائيه عاليه فمثلا تكون تحتوي
على اخطار النشويات الصحيه ال- النصف
الثاني من تكون من البروتينات والجزء
الاخر يكون من الخضروات والفواكه لانها
هاي التركيب من ال- ال- الطبق راح يساعد
على همم عدم الافراط باي نوع من المجموعات
الغذائيه وايضا تربيه الجسم من
المغذيات المغذيات الاخرى من الفيتامينات
والمعادن هيك انا باكون باركز على نوعيه
الاطعمه وايضا الكميه من خلال همم التركيز
على طبق المتوازن
السالم اختصاصيه التغذيه العلاجيه شكرا
جزيلا لك